autre secteur dans le flou le plus total
celui des discothèques et les nouvelles
aides de l'état s'annonce déjà
insuffisante le risque des fermetures
d'établissements
on en parle avec mon invité ce soir
bonsoir nicolas brault un bon soir vous
êtes gérant de la discothèque le new
wave à la croix en touraine déjà 257
jours de fermeture pour les boîtes de
nuit y at il des établissements qui ne
survivront pas à cette crise il y a déjà
des établissements qui n'ont pas survécu
puisqu'il faut savoir qu'il y en a déjà
100 qui ont déposé le bilan il y en a
300 qui sont aux portes des tribunaux de
commerce et notamment en france et en
indre et loire il ya déjà
malheureusement un établissement qui est
en sauvegarde environ combien de
discothèques aujourd'hui on est environ
entre 15 et 14 et 15 clubs en indre et
loire avec deux en campagne alors les
aides proposées par l'état 1 20 % de
votre chiffre d'affaires de 2010 neuf ou
dix mille euros par mois
à quoi vous servirai cet argent
aujourd'hui à payer les loyers à vous
payer une trésorerie pour redémarrer
qu'est ce que c'est à rien du tout c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui le but c'est
aujourd'hui le but on nous met sous
perfusion pour éviter de nous endetter
c'est tout et malgré tout on s'endette
puisque en plus les aides n'étaient pas
s'en passer de quinze mille à dix mille
les 20% du chiffre d'affaires c'est
mensuel donc les trois quarts du temps
pour les petits clubs ou les moyens club
c'est encore pire que de prendre les dix
milles entre guillemets vous ne vous y
retrouver pas là dedans pas du tout
c'est à dire qu'à moi j'ai douze mille
euros de charges fixes par exemple rien
à cacher je 2000 euros de charges fixes
aujourd'hui si je prends 20 % de mon
chiffre d'affaires ça me fait 5000 euros
sert pas le coup et si j'ai le droit aux
10000 pas forcément super 2000 et
sachant qu'en plus maintenant dans la
nouvelle mesure on va perdre les 1500
euros qu'on avait nicolas bron je
voudrais qu'on regarde quelques images
c'est votre discothèque des images sur
facebook 400 personnes en moyenne les
week-ends ça c'était à la bonne époque
qu on vient quand le gouvernement dit
que ce sont des lieux de propagation
qu'il faut les les fermes et ça peut se
comprendre non alors qu'on n'est pas moi
je le jure giry j'ai rien contre cette
idée là j'ai contre en ce moment par
contre m'empêche de faire mon travail
et puis on laisse le faire à tout un tas
d'associations on laisse le faire à tout
un tas de rassemblement clandestins qui
sont dénoncés il ya un certain là en ce
moment le à paris ce qui s'est passé
depuis le mois d'août tout le monde le
dénoncer ça a été arrêté comme en
novembre
on comprend pas trop pourquoi alors que
nous certains collègues ont ouvert un
soir le lendemain
vous avez fermeture administrative garde
à vue et tout ce qui s'en suit donc ça
ça on a beaucoup de mal alors
heureusement ça pourrait redémarrer
justement avec quelle mesure
alors aujourd'hui en fait y'a pas trente
six mille solutions effectivement les
très très gros clubs pourraient
éventuellement adapter un protocole
peut-être de distanciation etc
certains collègues ont fait le test
pourquoi pas c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous on voudrait
éventuellement proposer trois solutions
gouvernement clic et la distanciation
dans les discothèques lieux de drague
par excellence on est on est si je suis
bien d'accord certains collègues sont
pour le protocole moi personnellement je
suis complètement contre moi le jour où
j'aurai vu que je veux réouvrir en toute
liberté
parce que pour moi ça me paraît
compliqué effectivement mais en revanche
il est sûr que chez nous même si c'était
moins respectée qu'ailleurs ça serait
toujours plus respecté que dans les
fêtes clandestines
ça c'est une certitude et la preuve on
devait enclencher la deuxième vague
on était ferme elle la deuxième vague
quand même alors il faut vous réinventer
ce que c'est possible transformer les
discothèques en bar du gouvernement par
exemple ça c'est jouable c'est ça par
exemple alors effectivement il ya
peut-être certains clubs de centre-ville
qu'ils peuvent sur inventé se
transformer en barres ou autre chose
pour les clubs de campagne c'est
complètement on s'est complètement
compliqué c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
on voudrait que le gouvernement puisse
aussi penser à une revalorisation de nos
fonds de commerce pour qu'on puisse non
pas se réinventer dans notre domaine
mais pourquoi pas se transformer
vraiment autre chose aujourd'hui vous
êtes prêt à vendre votre fonds commerce
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
c'est ça un peu plus c'est ce qu'on fait
en fait quatre cent mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires donc mais faire une
autre activité
mais oui parce que j'ai pas le choix
sinon je suis en train de perdre ses 16
ans de ma vie ses 16 ans de ma vie qui
sont en train de partir en fumée je suis
en train de taper dans mes ressources
propres et voilà parce que faut pas
oublier que en tant que patron on a plus
de salaire nous on vit avec zéro donc
monsieur grise et a gentiment dit à une
de mes collègues que c'est nous qui
avions choisi voilà c'est nous qui
avions choisi d'être d'être patron
c'était notre problème oui enfin on a
choisi d'être patron pour pouvoir être
ouverts aussi donc ça et ça c'est ça
c'est notre problème découvert ça ce qui
nous en empêche qu'on dernier montre
rapidement c'est quoi la prochaine étape
pour vous faire autant prêt auprès d'un
gouvernement qui pour l'instant est
resté sourd à vos demandes
alors on essaie on multiplie tous les
moyens certains collègues choisissent de
manifester dans la rue nous par exemple
donnant se réunit avec certains patrons
du 37 du 41e
du 28 et du 45 pour essayer de faire une
petite vidéo justement on va dire au
gouvernement voilà il existe penchez
vous sur plusieurs solutions parce que
toutes les solutions sont pas bonnes le
20 % de chiffre d'affaires notamment il
est bon que pour les très gros club or
aujourd'hui on sait que les très bons
clubs robe pardon les très gros clubs en
france ça n'existe plus casier